we're seeing a drastic change in tone
from president trump on the coronavirus
after months of downplaying this
pandemic he's now echoing the warnings
of public health experts that the crisis
will likely
get worse before it gets better the last
thing anyone wants to hear right now the
u.s reported more than
one thousand deaths from the virus
yesterday it was one of the worst days
since may california is now poised to
overtake new york as the state with the
most confirmed cases
both have more than 400 thousand we've
got correspondents following this in
washington and in hard-hit states
we begin with maria villarreal in dallas
maria and some communities funeral homes
are simply overwhelmed local and state
officials agree
on the way to respond to this
yeah it's an absolutely dramatic
situation here in texas while we are
seeing a leveling off of cases
in a lot of urban areas like right here
in dallas border communities are seeing
their hospitals fill
up we have a lot of county judges are
stepping in they're actually
imposing curfews they're rolling back on
businesses that are non-essential
they're trying to close them up for the
time being
we even have one county judge who
imposed a stay-at-home ruling
despite the governor continuing to push
to keep the state open for business
i wanted to make everybody sure that
this is a serious situation
hidalgo county judge richard cortez says
his mandate to keep people home
was out of desperation my job is to take
care of the public health
i was seeing our people really not
paying attention to the weirdness of the
problem
but according to texas governor greg
abbott cortez's plan
and others under consideration are not
actually enforceable because
statewide rules take precedent is this
anything like you've seen before this
pandemic has really hit the value very
hard
it's something that i've never seen in
my 27 year career
johnny garcia is the director of the
ceballos diaz funeral home in edinburgh
texas
he says funeral homes like his are
running out of space so
fast the state brought in refrigerated
trailers
to help store bodies most funeral homes
can probably hold
you know five to ten loved ones at a
time
but all of a sudden you're getting that
many calls per day
according to the texas department of
state health services hispanic people
make up more than 40 percent of
confirmed coronavirus cases
it's a similar situation in california
where the number of cases has
topped 400 thousand latinos make up
almost 39 percent of california's
population
but account for more than 55 percent of
coronavirus cases
losing two members members within the
less than a week itself it's the hardest
thing you could go through
alexandria kubias lost her father luis
and sister stephanie to coronavirus just
days apart
gubia says she's angry and upset she
still sees people
not taking the virus seriously you need
to protect your family
you need to stay your distance you need
to stop being selfish
think about your family
other states are seeing an even bigger
surge compared to texas and california
in mississippi they recorded more than
1600 new coronavirus cases in one day
beating out their previous one-day
record by more than 30 percent
tony it may not be the last record to
fall maria thank you very much